okay so um
is the live stream going smoothly
okay um hi everyone uh it's my great
pleasure to present my recent work on a
rigorous and
robust quantum speed up in supervised
machine learning
this is joint work with my collaborators
at ibm
swinomas and crystal here's the archive
and journal reference
okay so one of the most significant
recent advances in the field of quantum
computing
is the exciting developments in this
experiments
for example until today we have seen a
total of four
quantum supremacy experiments and
following the demonstration of quantum
supremacy
the natural thing to do next is proof of
principle demonstration of quantum
algorithms
that can be implemented on current
devices
and which we should hope could
potentially achieve a quantum advantage
in the future
so this is indeed what many experimental
groups has been doing
so in this talk we will focus on one
particular quantum machine learning
algorithm
called quantum kernel methods which is
implemented in this experiment
and many others and we will show
theoretical evidence of quantum
advantage
using quantum kernel methods
so let's start with a high level
overview of quantum machine learning
algorithms
here by quantum machine learning i mean
that we want to use quantum computers
to speed up classical machine learning
problems
and there are many other schemes to
think about quantum machine learning
such as
in robert's talk where the data could be
generated quantumly
so the first class of quantum machining
algorithm is what we call
qram based algorithms here the basic
model is that
we use ampli coding amplitude encoding
where n-dimensional vector
which is a classical data is assumed to
be encoded
using only log n qubits
and therefore these algorithms can
achieve a polylog and running time
which is very fast
on the other hand there are also several
limitations with qram based algorithms
here we can understand the model as
following so we have
some classical input data and we
store them in qram and then use the
quantum machine algorithm to access data
from the qram
and generate some classical outputs
however
we know that qram is very hard to
implement in practice
and furthermore
the second limitation is that the
exponential speed up
of these algorithms disappears when we
think about the algorithm
as a end-to-end procedure in particular
if we think about the algorithm not as
the blue box
but as the red box then the exponential
speed up
disappears because it is unknown we if
we can
efficiently load data into qram
in other words the first step becomes
the bottleneck of the entire procedure
so arizona has a nice viewpoint article
on this issue
the third limitation is the existence of
dequantization arguments
developed by even town the argument is
that
in order to have a fair comparison
between classical and quantum machine
learning algorithms
since we are allowing quantum machining
algorithms to use qram
we should also allow classical
algorithms to use qram as well
which basically means that we are giving
classical algorithms
additional sampling access to data
and in this case it was shown that for
some problems
classical machine learning algorithms
can also achieve a polylogan running
time
which dequantizes the exponential
quantum speed up
given these three limitations
people have designed a different family
of
quantum machining algorithms that
directly
work on classical data so this is what
we call heuristic quantum machining
algorithms
including quantum neural net networks
quantum generating models kernel methods
etc
so these algorithms has the unique
advantage
of being implementable on near-term
hardware
however the main problem here
is that there has been little formal
evidence that shows that
these heuristic algorithms can have a
quantum advantage
so this is the challenge that we will
address in this talk
in particular
one central question we can ask here is
that
can heuristic quantum kernel methods
solve
any machine learning problem that is
hard classically
and our result shows that the answer is
yes
when this algorithm is implemented fast
tolerantly
so here is a brief summary of the
results
so quantum kernel methods is a family of
supervised classification algorithm
developed by ibm
and another group so here is the two
sentence summary of this algorithm
first classical data vectors
are mapped non-linearly to a quantum
state
by a quantum feature map
second a linear classifier in high
dimensional hilbert space can be
efficiently obtained
by the kernel method so our result is
the following
we show that this algorithm can probably
solve
a classification problem and this
problem is hard for all classical
organisms
so this result can be understood as
evidence
of end-to-end quantum speed up with this
algorithm
here end to end means that
we just have some classical input and
generate some classical output
and our algorithm needs to take care of
everything in between
okay so next i will give you more
details about the algorithm
let's start with a recap of classical
support vector machines and kernel
methods
so on the left hand side you can see a
set of training data
which is labeled by plus minus one as
indicated by the color
and the support vector machine algorithm
is just the convex optimization problem
on the right hand side
so here is one way to understand this
convex optimization
a very important quantity is what we
call the margin
which for a any data point essentially
means the distance
to a hyperplane in this picture
so it is very easy to see that this
convex optimization
is actually trying to maximize the
minimum margin of the training
set to the hyperplane so we can think
about this algorithm as
trying to put a very thick board in
between the training set
so here is a slightly more complicated
situation
where we could have some outliers and
the original convex optimization becomes
infeasible
so here the trick is to introduce some
additional penalty terms
as denoted by the psi variables
and this this convex optimization can be
understood as optimizing
the margin in some other higher
dimensional space
okay so this is still fine but here uh
it seems
we're in trouble because this picture is
clearly not
separable by any straight line
so however it's very clear that if we
could map this two-dimensional data set
to a three-dimensional sphere then the
data becomes easily separable by a
two-dimensional plane
so the way that people tackle machine
learning problem in practice
is to come up with a high dimensional
feature map
that maps low dimensional data to a high
dimensional feature space
and hope that it reduces to a situation
like this
and if we have this one we can use the
convex
optimization to find a good separating
hyperplane
but here is a new problem because the
dimension of this feature space
could be very high then
our convex optimization could
potentially become
inefficient due to the dimensionality
so the trick here is to use duality so
if we look at this convex
optimization and notice that here i
already replaced the data vectors
x with the feature vectors phi x so it
could live in a very
high dimensional space and if we look at
the
dual program of this convex optimization
notice that the feature vectors phi x
will only appear in this inner product
which we call the kernel function
so this gives us a way to do
training and testing in support vector
machines with a
high dimensional feature map because the
key point here is that
we can replace all of the high
dimensional vectors
with the kernel matrix k
and we can do the same thing in testing
that is after training if we receive a
new data example we can
compute the kernel and evaluate the
classifier
okay so this is known as the kernel
method in
machine learning where we do not specify
feature map
explicitly instead we define this
efficiently computable kernel function
and this is a very popular trick in
machine learning and
here are some examples of the classical
kernels widely used in practice
and of course they should be non-linear
because otherwise it is not doing
anything
non-trivial
okay so what about quantum kernel
methods
well here the only difference is that we
are replacing a classical kernel with a
quantum kernel
here by quantum kernel we mean that we
are encoding data
into a quantum state by a quantum
fissure map
so we map this classical data x into
this density matrix
which is parameterized by some unitary
circuit
and this is a way to represent a
non-linear function on a quantum
computer
so the reason we use density matrix here
is that
the inner product between two density
matrices which is the hebrew schmidt
inner product it's a physically
measurable quantity
okay so now we can see that the way to
implement this
quantum kernel on a quantum computer is
very simple
so we just have the input of zero and
run the circuit u
x i and then run this circuit u x j
dagger and measure
and we count the frequency of seeing the
all zero output
so here we are calling this procedure
quantum kernel
estimation which is highlighting the
fact that
this procedure is subject to a small
additive error due to finite sampling
because we can only take
a finite number of measurement shots so
this is why we call it
quantum kernel estimation
okay so now let's take a look at the
difference between classical svms and
quantum kernel estimation
so for classical svms we are we have a
classical training set
and we compute the kernel function for
each pair of training data
run the convex optimization obtain
classifier
and when testing we compute the kernel
function again
and for quantum kernel estimation it is
actually exactly the same
except that we are replacing compute
with estimate
and the only step
in the entire learning procedure that
requires a quantum computer is the
quantum kernel estimation routine
while all of the other optimizations are
performed classically
so so here are two main points regarding
classical
quantum kernel methods first
intuitively we should think of quantum
feature maps
are more expressive than classical
feature maps due to the
exponentially more powerful
computational power so we should hope
that
quantum figure maps can recognize
patterns
that classical feature maps cannot
recognize so this is the hope for
quantum advantage
however we also have this finite
sampling noise
that is the quantum kernel estimation
routine has this
one over poly sampling noise even if the
quantum computer is fault tolerant
so this is uh one thing that we need to
address
for proving a quantum advantage
so our result is a end-to-end
quantum speed up with this algorithm
which has two steps
first we construct a learning problem
and prove that it is hard for classical
algorithms
that is no efficient classical algorithm
can even achieve a
non-trivial performance on this data set
and second we show that we can solve
this problem
up to very high accuracy using quantum
kernel estimation
and along the way we also need to prove
that this
algorithm is robust to finite sampling
noise
so here is a sanity check the
learning problem that we construct could
potentially also be too hard for quantum
algorithms so we need to make sure that
this problem is in bqp
so the way we do this is to construct a
classification problem
that is as hard as discrete log so that
passes the sanity check because this
gridlock is in bqp
so one way to interpret this result is
that
for solving machine learning problems
quantum kernel estimation
can use the full power of quantum
computers
okay so next let's
take a brief look at how to prove that
kernel methods work so here we have this
familiar picture and
the data set on the left hand side is id
drawn from a distribution
so here is the intuition to understand
this picture
so after we having after having obtained
these training samples from the
distribution
we look at it and we realize that this
data set looks separable
and we can also efficiently find a good
separating hyperplane for this data set
and therefore if we draw a new
sample in the same distribution and
evaluate on this
classifier because of concentration
measure arguments we can intuitively
understand that this new
example should also lie on the correct
side of the hyperplane
so in statistical learning theory what i
just described is called a
generalization bound
which is that if we if this classifier
achieves good performance in training
then it should also achieve good
performance in testing
when it receives new examples
in particular what we use here is uh
known as
margin based generalization bound
that is if if we manage to find the
hyperplane the black line
that separates the data set by a large
margin which is the delta distance there
then the test error should be bounded by
by this margin in particular
we can see that actually the convex
optimization
that we are doing is actually trying to
minimize this upper bound on the test
error
so that looks great
in the most general case where we have
this high dimensional feature space
and we replace the data vectors by the
feature vectors phi x
we can essentially apply the same
information and
we can similarly show that this
the test error is upper bounded by this
training loss in the convex optimization
so this is still saying that the convex
optimization is directly trying to
optimize
trying to minimize the upper bound of
the test error
so here m is the number of training
samples
so the key point here is that large
margin
observed in training implies good
performance in testing
okay so using this tool
we can sort of go through the proof of
the quantum advantage
first we explicitly construct a quantum
feature map
or a kernel function that maps classical
data to a very high dimensional feature
space
and crucially show that the training
that is separated by a large margin by
this feature map
and next we run the duo program
using this quantum kernel and we are
guaranteed to find a good hyperplane
and next use the margin based
generalization bound
we can guarantee a high accuracy when
testing this classifier
and along the way we need to address
noise robustness
which can be obtained by strong
here one thing we use is that small
perturbations in the kernel will only
cause small perturbations
in the classifier and the large margin
sort of
protects the classifier from this
perturbation
okay so before concluding
i would like to mention
the complexity theoretic background
behind this work
which is known as quantum state
generation
a very beautiful paper by arnold arnold
aeronaut
i'm sorry our runoff and tashma
so here the intuition is that many
problems
can be solved by preparing certain
quantum states
and estimating their inner products this
is a general way of designing quantum
algorithms
for example sometimes we can prepare
such states
and the discrete log is such an example
we already show that
if if we could pair certain quantum
states and estimating their inner
product
this can be used to solve discrete log
and we
we know how to prepare such states and
we know how to
solve discrete log both are in bqp
so our construction of the quantum
kernel essentially follows from this
example
on the other hand
sometimes we also know that we also
don't know how to prepare such states
but we can establish a reduction
for example we know that graph
isomorphism
a well-known problem in computer science
is in bqp
if and only if the uniform superposition
over all permutation
of a graph can be prepared so we don't
know how to prepare
prepare this uniform superposition and
we don't know how to solve
graph isomorphism in bqp but we know
they are equivalent
okay so having introduced uh this
quantum state generation problem where
many problems can be
solved by preparing certain states and
estimating their inner product
we can immediately see that there is a
similarity
with quantum kernel estimation where
classical data
is mapped to high dimensional quantum
states
and the kernel matrix is obtained by
estimating their
inner products the two things look very
similar
so our result can be viewed
as establishing a formal connection
between the two things
on the one hand we can sort of use
quantum state generation as a complexity
theoretic background
that supports the quantum curve that
supports the quantum
advantage of the quantum kernel
estimation algorithm
on the other hand we also know that
preparing certain states or actually
certain uniform superpositions
is a very powerful way to solve many
problems
especially those with a group theoretic
structure
which is precisely where quantum
advantage
lies in this shows that
quantum kernel estimation is actually a
very well motivated quantum algorithm
with good reasons to hope for a quantum
advantage
so finally i can mention some
prospects and obstacles of quantum
advantage with quantum kernel estimation
one future direction is that we could
potentially improve our results
to bqp complete that is we can try to
construct a
learning problem that is bkb complete
and then solve it using quantum kernel
estimation
so our current construction is based on
discrete log which is not known to be
bqp complete
and secondly and perhaps more
importantly
we should try to find practical learning
problems
that are both challenging for classical
algorithms
and with the structure for potential
quantum speed up
because fundamentally we know that
quantum speed up
requires structure
and on the other hand there are also
obstacles
for obtaining a quantum advantage with
this algorithm
first we know that constant depth
2d quantum circuits do not have a
sympathetic advantage
due to a result of braviator in
particular their result
implies that if we use constant depth
2d circuits in the quantum kernel
estimation routine
then that process is similable
bioclassic algorithm and therefore the
entire learning procedure can be
efficiently classically simulated
and of course our result uses deep
polynomial depth circuits
finally we also have to admit that
there are already very powerful
classical
general purpose learning algorithms
especially deep neural networks
so uh it is very hard to imagine that we
can
actually up outperform these algorithms
on a generic learning problem but as i
just mentioned we should look for
this structure for a potential quantum
speed up
okay so finally i can give you one
example
in recent experiments that implements
this
quantum kernel estimation algorithm
so they used a 17 17 qubits on
google sigmoid device and try to do some
binary classification of some
cosmological data set
and the left hand side is the quantum
feature map that they use and we can see
that this is essentially
the same as what we just described
and this is implemented by a shallow
circuit
and they can also observe that in
simulations
the quantum kernel estimation algorithm
achieves similar performance as
classical svms and when they actually
implement this on a quantum computer
they can observe
a non-trivial accuracy
with 60 to 70 percent so this
is basically pretty much the state
of the art for current experimental
implementation of
these algorithms so
yeah that's all for for the talk thank
you
are there any questions
yeah there are several questions let me
see one question
um the question is as hhl already showed
the
completeness of quantum matrix inversion
why doesn't that automatically imply an
exponential separation between
classical and one machine learning via
discrete log
right so i think hhl still uses this
amplitude encoding because it assumes
some
input is provided in terms of quantum
states
and this is fundamentally a different
model
from our setting where the only input we
receive
is a set of classical vectors
and we need to find a way to load them
into quantum computers
so i would say that uh this is in a
different input model
and in the classical setting which is
what we are talking about
um sort of it's it is unclear
that heuristic quantum machine learning
algorithms
could in principle solve a hard problem
because the way that they use quantum
computers is not necessarily the most
general way
so our result is sort of solving that
challenge
thank you there's one more question
could you explain the plot on the last
slide in more detail
oh right um
okay um
yeah so the second okay so the first
figure
is the quantum fissure map that was
implemented in this experiment
where this is just a shallow circuit and
of course if you keep the
steps as the same and scale up to many
cubits this is still classically similar
and the second picture is the numerical
simulation of the
quantum kernel estimation routine and
you can see that they are comparing this
quantum fusion map
with rbf which is actually one of the
examples
of classical fissure maps that i just
described before so they can observe a
similar performance
in testing after doing some training and
finally in this
experimental implementation um the
accuracy of course drops because of the
noise
but it's still beyond 60 which is uh
sort of a non-trivial accuracy
okay uh it doesn't seem like there are
any more questions but
thank you again
i think we have some time for the next
one so